dimanche c'est la fête des mères les
plus organisés d'entre vous ont déjà
leurs cadeaux depuis plusieurs jours
bixente mariant santisteva ne bonsoir
alors vous vous avez pensé aux
retardataires et vous nous donner
quelques idées
c'est ça oui exactement la fête des
mères c'est une journée si particulière
où pour une fois ce sont les enfants qui
prennent soin de leur maman après une
pas une année passée enfermé chez soi ce
sont surtout des cadeaux type activités
qui seront plébiscités si vous sentez
que votre mère a besoin de se détendre
un petit peu vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
réserver un massage en soins au spa de
l'hôtel de la corniche harold boss ou
encore à l'atelier de massage à
versailles par exemple avec le beau
temps j'imagine qu'on peut faire aussi
des activités en extérieur
exactement c'est là donc il ya le déjà
re devenu classique restant en terrasse
mais on peut aussi aller chercher dans
le plus original il existe des ateliers
pour découvrir les trésors de la nature
ça s'appelle le temps de savoir faire
plusieurs activités sont proposées il
dure de deux à sept heures dans la forêt
de marly et alors qu'elle est l'atelier
le plus susceptible de plaire aux mamans
c'est probablement là la découverte des
plantes comestibles
une petite balade pour apprendre à ne
pas se tromper entre les différents
produits de la nature
brémond flamands font des fondateurs du
temps des savoir-faire nous en parle
apprendre à être vraiment à l'aise sur
la reconnaissance de plantes sauvages
comestibles et ensuite comment les
préparant cuisine parce qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la plupart
des plantes qui sont qu'on peut trouver
dans une forêt comme la forêt de marly
dans laquelle on fait les animations
c'est des plantes parfois qui sont
utilisés dans les plus grands
restaurants gastronomiques puisqu'ils
ont des goûts qui sont assez inattendue
est un peu un peu oublier d'autres
activités comme la découverte de la
vannerie de l'argile la fabrication
d'objets comme le hochet ou une cuillère
en bois sont proposés pour les prix il
varie de 19 à 79 euros donc adaptable à
tous les budgets
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le temps de savoir
faire point com et comme cerise sur le
gâteau ou plutôt sur le cadeau en petits
bouquets de fleurs ne sera pas trop un
oui très bonne idée il y as d'autant
qu'il ya une fleur à la mode pour cette
fête des mères c'est la pivoine
catherine phalempin gérante des fleurs
du manet à montigny le bretonneux nous
explique pourquoi c'est parce que c'est
une fleur qui
est très en vogue depuis quelques années
et c'est une fleur que nous avons en
gros pendant un mois souvent elles
commencent au nom à la fête des mères
nous les clients ont pratiquement toute
l'année nous demandent des pivoines les
roses nous en avons toute l'année la
pivoine c'est un mois alors on revient
souvent souvent sur la pivoine on en
profite puisque ça dure pas longtemps
attention cependant les stocks de ce
dimanche risque d'être un peu limité
avec le mauvais temps de mais la saison
sera sûrement décalé d'environ deux
semaines
rien ne vous empêche cependant de vous
rabattre sur d'autres classiques comme
les orchidées au les roses qui font
aussi leur petit effet merci beaucoup un
vicente pour toutes ces idées